really there's benefits to be in second
place I mean didn't Ricky Bobby's father
say second place is the first loser even
I think Vince Lombardi once said a
winning isn't everything it's the only
thing right so Patrick how can you do a
value taemin episode titled titled the
benefits of being second place right and
you'll understand what I'm talking about
here as I get into my message because I
think it's very important for you to
realize that before Apple became first
place they will last or second place for
a long time before anybody becomes first
place they're not first for a very very
long time and this is a very important
strategy for you to be paying attention
to today as in entrepreneurs you're
building your business because there's a
lot of power behind it so the way I want
to explain to you the power of this is
by giving you story in the rental car
business there are two companies that
we've all heard about when you have
herds and you have ages these guys rent
cars for a living that's how they make
their living by renting cars many many
years ago Avis kept trying to be hurt so
here's what they did they kept trying to
say we're going to be first place we're
going to be first place we're going to
be first place we're better than hurt
we're better than hurts we're better
than hers didn't work they tried this
campaign for 13 straight years and you
know what happened for 13 straight years
for APHIS they lost money not even zero
they lost money 13 straight years
Avis lost money hurt kept making money
they kept losing money finally the
marketing can come together and listen
guys this is not working out we are not
first place let's stop trying to do this
and let's change our entire marketing
plan and it said what do you have in
mind well here's what we need to do are
we 1st place you know hurts this first
place we're second place yes why don't
we say that what do mean why don't we
say that why don't we tell the customer
we're second place and because we're
second place this matters to us you
matter to us has this guy lost his mind
no we need to do that because there's
two different types of customers what
are the different types of customers you
have customers that love underdog
companies and they always want to buy
from underdog company
and you have customers that always want
to buy some the best I only buy the best
I only buy the best and you know what's
the difference between these two types
of customers you ready for this here's
the difference the number one customers
are bandwagon customers you know how
these fans always change the best
favorite team they have because it's a
new team that's winning now so now
they're the bandwagon fan so one way
that seemed start to lose it now there
is this man autumn a Miami Heat fan no
no I'm a Cleveland Cavaliers fan because
if I don't care what fine up as long as
someone's winning I'm a fan of the
number ones right but then you have the
loyal fans Chicago Cubs loyal fans
Red Sox loyal fans there are loyal fans
these are loyal fans that stick around
and say listen have been a cup stand for
29 years I'm just a loyal fan because
I'm a loyal to them because there's a
certain emotional connection to an
underdog company there's a certain
emotional connection to an underdog
organization or sports team I'm
connected to them I'm not emotionally
connected here I just want to know that
they're the best and this changes all
the time because almost stage number one
forever but underdog it's forever this
lasts a lifetime
okay so Avis versus Hertz finally this
guy convinces everybody in the company
that our marketing campaign moving
forward is the following
Avis is only second in rental cards so
why do business go with us
because we try harder because we try
harder because we try harder meaning we
can't afford to lose you
Hertz can lose you're just another
customer they get so many of them but we
can't afford to lose you mean a lot to
us the moment they change your marketing
plan to this you know what happened make
sure they made 1.2 million dollars in
profits then 2.6 million dollars of
profits then five million dollars of
profits then you know what happened a
new regime came and they went back to
what we're going to be number one and
then it started losing again if they
would have stuck to this game plan they
would have eventually passed them up but
because they just did too soon they
didn't pass them up so it's important
for you to realize as you're building
your business if you're sitting with
somebody and your client asks you the
following thing and your client ask you
question and they say well you know
what's the
difference between UN XYZ company they
say they're number one right you're
ready what you're going to say here's
what you're going to say mr. Jones
ma'am you are right they are number one
but this is why you matter to us more
they can afford to lose you see I can't
afford to lose you I have to do my best
to make sure I earn your loyalty and
that means a lot you and I hope that
means a lot to you as much as it means
to me because I want to do whatever I
can to make sure you are serviced
properly at the highest possible level
so if that's important to you I would
highly recommend you do business with me
does that make any sense
yes it does can we move forward no
problem take that approach and do not be
afraid to sit with people that will
gorillas I'm going to industry myself
when we are not number one there's a lot
of guys bigger than us but we are doing
our part we are doing our part and
quietly we've been we've been grown and
as we simply these other gasm and we're
doing our part we have done our best to
treat our agents better than anybody
else our customers our executives our
staff every our partners because it
matters to us it matters to us while the
guys at the top want to bully were
coming up is what we're doing and we're
doing our best to take care of everybody
more take that approach as an
entrepreneur while you're doing your
business that you'd be amazed how much
more customers will love the fact that
you're being transparent with them and
how much more they're going to
appreciate the fact that you're going
above and beyond everybody else to make
sure you service those customers the
employees the clients the partners the
vendors that I've chosen to do business
with you so with that being said the
messages there are a lot of benefits to
be in second place this is definitely
one of them by the way if you eventually
end up being first place you got to kind
of adjust your marketing strategy just
so you know that because it doesn't work
once you become first place then you got
to have a call whole different up play
that you got to have in order for you to
get up there so far let's get that
pillow right here brother
this was a a one of our Paul good throw
hey if you haven't subscribed to this
channel yet please do so they keep
telling me to point on this side I don't
know what it is I'm gonna try to point
on this side this time notification
Scott will remind me if you haven't
subscribed do subscribe to the channel
if you haven't yet joined a notification
squad click on a large bow but you'll be
wander
to be alerted every time we have a new
video that comes up on value 10 you'll
be one the first to get in and by do if
you have any questions any thoughts
comment on the bottom below and with
that being said thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]